هناك عديد من التفاصيل وهذه المنطقه يبدو
انها منطقه ساخنه خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه نتعرف عليها اكثر عبر الخريطه اذا
مشاهدينا الكرام نتحدث عن منطقه حدوديه
بالغه الاهميه بين مصر واسرائيل هذه هي
الحدود التي تمتد
لحوالي 200 كيلومتر من رفح حتى طاب ونتحدث
عن وسط هذه الحدود كما نشاهد على الخريطه
تقريبا في هذه النقطه معبر العوجه كما
نشاهد على الخيطين اقترب اكثر من هذه
المنطقه نتحدث عن منطقه النقب هذه المنطقه
الكبيره التي
التي تشهد عاده عمليات او محاولات لتهريب
المخدرات بين الجانبين المصري والاسرائيلي
وتنشط فيها
عمليات تهريب المخدرات كما ذكرنا ولكن هذا
الحدث اليوم يا الفتنه اكثر الى انه حدث
امني كما ذكرت المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه وبعض وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيلي واكد الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الحدث حدث امني معبر كما نشاهد على
الخريطه يبعد عن معبر كرم ابو سالم على
حدود قطاع غزه حوالي اربعين كيلو متر كما
نشاهد اربعين الى 42 كيلو مترا وبالتالي
الفرضيات في امكانيه تسلل او تحركات من
قطاع غزه لا تبدو انها منطقيه في هذا
الشان الامور الان تتجه نحو الاراضي
المصريه والقدوم من الاراضي المصريه
ومهاجمه هذه النقطه وتحديدا ممكن القول ان
منطقه القسيمه في المنطقه الجنوبيه من
معبر العوجه قد تكون هي احدى المناطق
الرئيسيه التي انطلق منها منفذ هذه
العمليه او منفذون هذا الهجوم بشكل اساسي
اذا ما انتقلنا اكثر الى هذه النقطه معبر
العوجه فهذه الصوره القريبه هذه هي الحدود
المصريه الاسرائيليه وهذا هو السياج
الفاصل كما نشاهد على الخريطه الذي يفصل
هذه الحدود هذا المعبر كما نشاهد هذه
النقطه الاسرائيليه من وهذه النقطه
المصريه من المعبر على على طرفي الحدود
هذا المعبر مخصص بشكل اساسي لحركه البضائع
والدبلوماسيين وتدخل الشاحنات وتتحرك من
من الاراضي المصريه باتجاه داخل الخط
الاخضر وايضا من داخل الخط الاخضر باتجاه
الاراضي المصريه عبر هذه النقطه النقطه
الحدوديه بالغه الاهميه والتي تقع في
المنطقه او قريبه كما ذكرنا من منطقه
القسيمه كما نشاهد على الخريطه لتكون هذه
المنطقه منطقه الان تحت الاعين عمليات
التمشيط التي يتحدث عنها الجميع تشمل هذه
المنطقه نتحدث عن عمق حوالي 10 الى 15
كيلومترا داخل الاراضي المصريه ايضا
بالمقابل عمق 10 الى 15 كيلو مترا داخل
اراضي 48 في اشتباه اسرائيلي بامكانيه
بقاء المسلح اما ان يكون داخل هذه المنطقه
داخل الاراضي 48 او انه دخل الحدود وغادر
اي انه قطع الحدود مرتين دخل السياج
الفاصل وعاد الى المنطقه المصريه لتكون
هذه المنطقه كما نشاهد على الشاشه هي
منطقه التوتر دائره حوالي نصف قطرها عشره
كيلو متر هي دائره الاشتباه الان وهي
دائره التمشيط العمليات الاسرائيلي مع
تحليق مكثف للطيران الاسرائيلي في المنطقه
بحثا عن اي تفاصيل او اضافات قد تفيد في
من ينفذ هذه العمليه التي ادت الى مقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص التفاصيل حتى الان تقول بان
العمليه بدات الساعه الرابعه ونصف صباحا
وان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اكتشف العمليه
بعد اكثر من ساعتين الى ثلاث ساعات اي ان
هذا الامر اعطى ممثل هذه العمليه الفرصه
للتحرك اكثر والانتقال اكثر بين المنطقتين
اما انه كما ذكرنا غادر عفوا هذه هذا
العلم المصري في هذه المنطقه اما انه بقي
في هذه المنطقه وهو الان موجود داخل
الاراضي 48 انه عاد وبالتالي انسحب من
المكان حتى هذه اللحظه هذه التفاصيل
المتاحه نتحدث عن حدود يبلغ طولها 200
كيلومتر نتحدث عن نقطه تبعد عن بل رفع
حوالي 40 كيلومتر وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن
نقطه من الممكن القول بانها منطقه
مضروبه امنيا او ممكن ان تكون هشه امنيه
لانها مسافه طويله صحيحه ان الجغرافيا
وعره في هذه المنطقه ولكن طول الحدود يصعب
من عمليات التمشيط والتفتيش عن منفذ او
منفذي هذه العمليه التي وقعت صباح هذا
اليوم بطبيعه